[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so interesting day yesterday and i
thought aaron rodgers was very calm
almost surgical in what he was saying
how he was saying it but also
i think you have to understand you got
to take emotion out when you
are going to cut somebody or not sign
somebody
and that's something that aaron aaron
had a motion in that that hey these guys
weren't treated well these guys
weren't but if you look at these guys
what they did after they left green bay
i mean jordy nelson played one year with
the raiders and was done clay matthews
didn't do anything with the rams
uh julius peppers i mean you have these
guys and i think when emotions attached
to it
that's not great if i'm using you as a
sounding board and you're using emotion
uh and i think that's where it gets
dangerous with how much
how much input you you uh take in from
aaron rodgers
pete doherty is covering the packers
columnist for the green bay press
gazette usa today
as well pete where do you want to start
on this situation with her how about we
pick up
where i was uh i left off there with
aaron talking about
former players and how they were treated
what's the message he's sending there
yeah you know i'm i'm on board with uh
with your take there you know i unders i
totally get why these
quarterbacks wanna say in personnel
rogers is really smart
he's played in the league forever he's
one of the best players in the league
um so i understand why he would want to
say and you know whose receivers are and
all that but like you said
like you said you get attached to guys
and football you have to be ruthless
about personnel i mean going back to
even lombardi
he was ruthless with guys until the very
end that last team he had was pretty old
but he basically through most of the 60s
was he'd tell guys
time for you to retire you know really
good great players
hall of fame players so you get attached
to guys
and you keep them too long and then in
the nfl
guys go from being pretty good to not
very good
it happens fast and you've got to be
proactive
about turning your roster and moving on
from those guys regardless of what they
did for you no matter how much you love
them
and how good they were and so that's the
danger of giving a quarterback
a lot of say in in personnel decisions
that's why you even have a gm
and a coach because the coach gets
attached to guys the gm has a little
more distance there
are you uh did yesterday's press
conference make you lean one way or
another about rogers playing
you know longer than this upcoming
season with the packers you mean yeah
um didn't really change my thinking but
it kind of reinforced as of right now i
mean it just looks
really unlikely that he'll be their
quarterback in 2022 but i will say
you know the the nfl is a little bit
like a season's a little bit like dog
years right
i mean six and a half months who knows
what could happen maybe they
do things and could lean on him more and
personnel than they have
up to this point in decisions at least
listen to him more
and maybe they win the super bowl and
maybe he would see
winning a super bowl is the perfect way
to leave or maybe he'd see that they
have a really good team and would think
they could win two or three more so
the landscape could change dramatically
in six and a half months but right now
if you had to bet you'd have to bet that
this will be his uh
his last season with the team if you're
management do you let the comments
just kind of settle and and you move on
from this
does management come back and offer up a
rebuttal to anything that rogers said
yesterday
i don't think i would uh
i you know if you want to
be real subtle about it i just would do
nothing to inflame the situation
um you know he deserved to have his say
uh i think he
i wonder if he felt it was kind of
cathartic for him to finally publicly
you know air what his grievances were
instead of having it all you know be
mysterious but no i think i would just
let it lie because if you're the team
the most important thing is
the guy showed up he showed up on time
he's got a lot to play for
i think he does like the coach and the
staff and his teammates
and they you know i mean you look at
their personnel and what they did last
year
and with him at quarterback i mean you
got to think that their chances
objectively looking at it their chances
are about as good as anybody's aren't
they
what would inflame the situation from
management's
side of this oh if yeah you know
disputed any of the factual things he
said or his characterizations about not
being listened to
the one thing that they might want to
defend themselves about is
because they do treat players really
really well here um you know
they're treated like kings over there
and in this town they really are
um so i don't think that's the issue i
think he was talking more about when
they depart
and it's just the cold the cold side of
it when guys are cut or not even offered
contracts and they've been really good
players like
clay matthews you know and that's harsh
but that's the harsh
that's the nfl that's the business i
think it's i think it's that way with
pretty much most teams maybe all teams
and maybe they could be a little better
about it but they were even harsher with
ted thompson now they
at least make good acoustic available
when they uh when they move on from a
really good player ted thompson you just
sent out a one
one sentence release saying we've cut
you know uh
you know jordy nelson or whoever what
kind of dog you got there i i heard the
dog there
yeah that's winston he's like a two of
them there's a cocker spaniard there's
always a danger of uh
doing this a barking fit could not break
out in any way
wait wait you didn't name one mikowski
or i'm on green
or no i like to i like to go with uh
i've had like walter and edward i kind
of go with kingly kind of names this is
uh
that's winston i got connor too he's a
rescue but uh
no we stay away from the packers for the
names did people
react in a way with the uh the local jab
you know
green bay is not exactly a vacation spot
that do
uh the locals take that personally about
i mean aaron is saying something that's
factual you're trying to get free agents
there
and no it's probably not the hotbed of
where you want to be if you're young
single uh did people take offense to
them
i saw you know one or two tweets and
they actually
i think two and they both kind of looked
they were more tongue-in-cheek
so i don't have much else to go on okay
i'm guessing
you know it might have bothered some
people but i think people are
realistic enough to know that you know
this isn't miami
do we know what the packers think of
jordan love
really um i think even off the record
when i talk to people
i don't get the sense that they're
really
i wouldn't believe them no matter what
they said unless they said they didn't
like him
you know you just and it's hard to tell
and he didn't prac he didn't
get all that many snaps in practice last
year you know he was splitting the
number two snaps in camp and camp was so
short
uh so no i think and they're giving him
a lot of work he got a lot of work in
the offseason
and i'm assuming he'll play you know 90
of the snaps in the preseason games i'll
be surprised if rogers even suits up for
any of those
pete great to talk to you and uh you
know you got your gift yesterday with
rogers i mean
this is going to be a fun season to
cover
it will it'll be interesting and um
it'll be hovering over them all year but
you know
they've got a good team and uh so their
hopes are still high here
thank you pete thanks dan that's pete
doherty he uh covers the packers the
green bay
press gazette also usa today